Agustín Da Silva is from Misiones, a province in northeast Argentina
that’s known for its yerba mate.
More than 700,000 tons of yerba mate are harvested here each year.
90 percent of the workers are indigenous Guaraní and underage.
Agustín was exceptional.
He could pick 650 pounds of yerba mate in 10 to 12 hours. For that, he'd take home $8 a day.
But his fate changed the morning he met Irma Silvera.
While in school, Agustín fell in love with running.
Agustín's living conditions did not go unnoticed.
A newspaper story questioned his future as a runner because of his poor nutrition.
Agustin used that article to find a food sponsor.
Private sponsors give Agustín money when he wins a race.
And it's much more than what his family make picking yerba mate.